Introversion and extraversion are terms
first coined by psychiatrist Carl Gustav Jung
in Switzerland in the 1920s
according to Jung an extravert seeks
intensive contact with the outside world
an introvert instead turns the psychic
energy inwards. Jung believed that no one
is a hundred percent extravert or a
hundred percent introvert instead we
carry both traits
however most minds tend to lean either
to one side or the other.
If both characteristics are equally
present we can speak of someone who has
an ambivert personality. In the 1960s the
psychologist Hans Eysenck added to Carl
Jung's ideas.He argued that the main
difference between introverts and
extraverts lies in the way they gain and
recharge their mental energy. By Nature,
introverted people have a higher level
of brain activity and therefore feel a
greater need to shield themselves from
external stimuli. By withdrawing
themselves they gain mental energy. The
neuronal activity of extraverts is lower.
They overcome this lack by exposing
themselves to external stimulation this
charges their inner batteries. To
illustrate the difference let's compare
two imaginary children: Jay is
extraverted. He loves to be surrounded by
classmates. He enjoys being the center of
attention and loves to talk to his
buddies about all kinds of stuff.
He organizes football games with
strangers and right after is open to
playing ping-pong with someone else.
By seeking social stimuli he gains mental
energy. Ann is introverted. As others play
around in the park, she often enjoys
sitting alone watching. At home, she
plants herbs in the garden, all by
herself. She slowly becomes a real expert
in this field but that's her secret.
To recharge her batteries Ann needs peace and quiet time.
Introverts are not necessarily shy, even
if it appears they like to
walk away from small talk. Ann in fact is not shy at all. She is not afraid to talk to anyone,
not even seniors. When too many people are around and the conversations
become superficial or confusing she gets
super tired. Her strategy is to fade out
and go inside herself to recharge
through silence. Jay loves to have many
people around him, to jump from one
conversation to the next stimulates him.
Some experts claim that extraverts and
introverts use different brain areas to
form their thoughts. An extravert tends
to use short term memory and therefore
is able to come to fast associations Jay
therefore talks fast and a lot.
He appears smart because his brain always offers an answer quickly.
However he often speaks before he thinks
and later changes his mind.
Someone like Ann works with her brain to
carefully retrieve information from her
long-term memory. Her thoughts are more
complex and hence need more time to
develop. She therefore thinks first and
then speaks. If the two were asked for
directions by a tourist Ann would spend
time thinking about the best answer
while Jay would have already come up
with different kinds of options.
Good teachers and clever business leaders
know about the different nature of
introverts and extraverts and try to
develop their strengths. When raising
questions they ask everyone to think for
a minute in silence before answering.
Extraverts then learn to formalize their
thoughts before they speak and
introverts get more talking time to
practice public speaking.
At brainstorming they use a formal process
or a talking stick to make sure an Ann
also gets to participate.
Group projects can be formalized to
support both temperaments. In one project
extraverts and introverts work together.
Jay then learns from Ann how to think
ideas over to develop more complex
thoughts. Ann in return benefits from
Jay's fast association skills and learns
to think and speak more flexibly. In the
next project the same temperaments work
together. Then they see their own traits
in the opposite person. If confronted
with problems in teams of the same
character introverts need to speak up
and extraverts are forced to think deep
to proceed. The educator Rudolf Steiner
was a proponent of this method for his
Waldorf schools. Psychologist Jerome
Kagan's research on temperament in
Toddlers showed that many character
traits we are born with make it into
adulthood. He confronted 500 babies with
different stimuli like loud sounds and
bad smells. Around 20% of the babies
cried or got nervous,
40% stayed relaxed and the other 40%
were somewhere in between. A second test
years later showed, that babies who
didn't react strongly turned out to be
more extraverted. What about yourself? Do
you consider yourself more introverted
or extraverted? Or do you think this
classification is flawed and there is no
such thing? Please share your thoughts in
the comments below.
Millions of students from all around the
globe have watched our Sprouts Videos
for better learning. Thousands of
teachers play them in their classrooms
to start projects volunteers on YouTube
have translated them to over
25 languages. Our mission is to promote
learning by doing in classrooms around
the world. If you are a great explainer
and a passionate teacher and you want to
help us develop outstanding content,
contact us! To support our channel with a
donation visit patreon.com/sprouts.